près 1 2 mais jack oui le phénomène drag
queen débarque en france dans les années
[Musique]
les drag queen des hommes en majorité se
joue des codes liés au genre faudra
compter deux ans dans un petit peu c'est
un collage un peu maladroit mais c'est
très vrai c'est le cas des deux genres
de sexualité mais alors plus trace
sexuée c'est à dire ces trois heures de
musculation continuer au gymnase clame
mais le soir je sors mon bois à paris
leur lieu phare c'est le banana café
loin de leur quotidien la nuit elle
s'exprime sans limites parce que je
vends le père thomas quinn
je me permettrai pas de leur petit
garçon donc j'en profite d'être dans un
club pour pouvoir délivrer un maximum
comme ça quand quand tu as mal quand je
travaille pas au chaud car trop je reste
stable sur jeans baskets et je pose
incognito la nuit monde de l'irréel de
tous les possibles mais aussi en refuge
tout de même un hiver pour une grande
majorité des homosexuels
il ya une menace
en priorité sur semi bio qui est le sida
et les drag queen vivre avec cela
c'est une façon de faire un pied-de-nez
à la mort aussi le cinéma et la musique
s'approprie le phénomène let me be a
drag queen du groupe français sister
queen se classe 9e ou top 50 en 1995 on
est intéressé par sister queen parce que
on avait un deuxième potentiel qui est
que c'était la première fois un groupe
de drag queen avait un disque qui était
crédible alors que d'habitude et drag
queen dans sur les disques des autres et
petits 2 c'est que le visuel était très
nettement supérieur à la moyenne du
groupe dance et quand on savait qu'on
allait développer le produit beaucoup
plus grâce à ça au coût de drag queens
sont invités à se produire dans les
soirées
elle attire les foules dans les boîtes
de nuit mais sont mal payés pour une
soirée
eliane touche 700 francs soit 146 euros
c'est trop c'est trop ambitieux pour moi
mais ça me permet de vivre ça et j'ai et
je dis bon maintenant et c'est très bien
pour plus de reconnaissance en 1996
le milieu se structure on est quand même
la première agence française créée sur
paris spécialisée dans les drag queen
après s'être estompée à la fin des
années 90 la scène drag queen ressurgit
trente ans après
[Musique]
oh